- That Roe is dead opens more
questions than it answers.
What happens next after
the Dobb's decision?
Well, today we're going to look at some
of the most pressing
issues from trigger laws
to abortion pills, to
federal codification of Roe.
And we start with the idea
of whether states can
criminalize abortion.
The answer here is
obviously yes they can now.
The Supreme Court ruled
that states have the right
to regulate abortion
because abortion laws now
are subject to rational basis review,
which means that as long as
they have any rational reason
for passing a law,
it will pass, and that means that states
can now criminalize abortions.
Before Roe vs. Wade, two-thirds
of states outlawed abortion
with some making it a criminal offense.
The majority opinion in Dobbs says
that women do not have a
fundamental right to privacy
when it comes to abortions.
And therefore, the opinion
took no official stance
on whether it was okay for states
to prosecute women
abortion service providers,
or people who helped
women obtain an abortion
that will be left up to the state
and the states will be able
to criminalize that if they so desire.
And obviously looking state
by state the situation
in many states is in flux.
There are 27 states where
abortion is protected
and are likely to stay that way.
Abortion protective
states are passing laws
to create safe havens
for people who travel
from out of state.
Now, Connecticut passed a law saying
that its agencies will not participate
in any investigations,
lawsuits, prosecutions,
or anything related
to abortions performed in Connecticut.
The state residents will also be allowed
to countersue if they are
sued for offering help
to abortion patients in another state.
This is in response to the
Texas bounty hunter law,
and New York, Illinois and California
are debating similar efforts.
Of course, once states begin denying
each other's citizens certain rights,
this invites more conflict
for the courts to decide.
What about comity between the states
these interstate conflicts could redefine
how much sovereignty states
have in this federal assistant.
And then there are the trigger laws.
13 states had trigger laws
on the books that banned
abortion as soon as Roe and Casey
were overturned.
These 13 states would trigger laws
had exceptions to save the
life of the pregnant woman,
but only five of these states
have exceptions for rape or incest.
And if someone becomes pregnant
by a male relative in Arkansas,
Kentucky, Louisiana, Missouri,
North and South Dakota,
Tennessee, Texas or Mississippi,
they will be forced to give birth,
and if someone is raped in those states,
they will also be forced to give birth.
- And I just have never
believed that having a tragedy
or a tragic situation happened to someone
is a reason to have another tragedy occur-
- So no exception for rape or incest?
- We continue to make sure we go forward.
- There are five states including Texas
where abortion is banned,
and there are eight states
where abortion will soon be banned.
And there are of course a huge variety
of different pro-choice
and anti-abortion laws
throughout the country.
Different states have different cut offs,
some are based on viability
others on a number of weeks.
Some allow exceptions for rape and incest
and some do not and it's only
going to get more complicated
as states rush to ban or allow abortion.
But what about the fetal heartbeat bills?
Until the Dobb's ruling
federal courts had unanimously struck down
the so called heartbeat
bills outlawing abortion
after the detection of a fetal heartbeat.
And that's why states like
Ohio, Georgia, South Carolina
and Iowa passed trigger laws
with six week abortion bans.
Legislators did not repeal those
laws and abortion is banned
after the sixth week of
pregnancy in those states.
The Supreme Court decision
did not say that states
had to allow abortion until week six
so any of those states are
free to pass total bans
if they desire though,
the Georgia law is currently
enjoined by the court.
And then of course,
much has been said about
potential religious exceptions.
Many states have laws on the
books that allow pharmacists
to refuse to fill prescriptions,
if they have moral or
religious objections.
And with the Supreme Court's
ever increasing deference
to individual religious liberties,
we may see more pharmacists
and medical providers claiming a right
not to fill prescriptions
for abortion medication or
participate in services,
like surgery to remove
an ectopic pregnancy.
And it's unclear how those
cases would be treated.
It's similarly unclear how
the court would treat a claim
of religious liberty claiming
that based on certain religious beliefs,
abortion is mandated in
certain circumstances,
even in a state that outlaws abortion.
Who knows how the court is
going to come down on that.
But it's also possible
continued jurisprudence
from this Supreme Court could
answer all of these questions
and the negative and
simply outlaw abortion.
Constitutional rights currently
only attached to people
who are already born the
debate in Roe, Casey and Dobbs
was overbalancing a woman's right
to the state's interest.
But anti-abortion activists argue
that individual rights
should attach to embryos
and fetus sometimes at
the point of conception,
putting them on equal legal
grounds as a born human being.
Now, the theory that unborn lives
or potential life are included
in the constitutional concept
of persons is not particularly developed
and the unborn have never been counted
in the US Census for example.
They've also never been treated as persons
for purposes of constitutional rights.
However, Justice Alito left the door open
to fetal personhood in the Dobb's opinion.
In Roe versus Wade,
the court said, "That the unborn
have never been recognized
in law as persons in the whole sense."
The Casey the court said,
"That a woman has a
right to an abortion up
until the point in which
the fetus could be viable
and live outside the mother."
And even after that point,
there are medical situations
where women would need an abortion
to save her life and
that would be allowed.
But in a doctor's opinion,
Justice Alito declined to
say exactly when rights
should attach to potential life,
but he criticized Roe
and Casey for attempting
to draw that line.
However, Alito himself
use the same terminology
that was used in Roe and Casey that
of potential human life
without agreeing with it,
which is often a linguistic
trick that signals
that he actually disagrees
with that conception of it.
This Supreme Court is
already treading new ground
with respect to what
qualifies as deeply rooted
within the history of the United States
are necessary for ordered liberty.
And is it entirely possible
that they might find
that Liberty interests or
personhood attaches to potential
or unborn life.
Six states already have introduced fetal
personhood legislation in 2022.
And the situation in Arizona
gives us a pretty good idea
of how complicated this issue may become.
The state enacted a 15 week abortion ban,
but that was before the
doctor's opinion made it legal
to ban all abortions.
Arizona simultaneously enacted a policy
that gives potential
life to full personhood.
The state's interpretation
policy states the following:
"The laws of the state
shall be interpreted
and construed to acknowledge,
on behalf of an unborn
child at every stage
of development, all rights,
privileges and immunities
available to other persons,
citizens and residents of the state,
subject only to the Constitution
of the United States
and decisions interpreting thereof
by the United States Supreme Court."
This interpretation policy incorporates
the statutory definition
of unborn child set forth in
Arizona law which provides
that an unborn child is "The
offspring of human beings
from conception until birth."
As written the law could impact a woman
throughout her pregnancy,
giving the state the ability to regulate
how she handles basically
every aspect of that pregnancy.
And as written, it could
encompass fertilized eggs
which would have the same
status as a born human being,
triggering limitations on
abortion medications and even IVF.
The ACLU of Arizona and the
Center for Reproductive Rights
sued to block implementation of this law,
and the court is scheduled
to have a hearing
on this lawsuit in July.
But if the Supreme Court
adopted such a definition
as being mandated by the Constitution,
we presumably prevent all
abortions in all 50 states.
And that brings us to the
potential national provision
of abortion pills through the mail.
Now over half of all abortions
in the United States are done
with medication which means
that they are induced by pills.
In 2021, the Food and Drug
Administration the FDA decided
to allow abortion pills giving
providers the green light
to distribute them by mail.
The medication which is used
during the first 10 weeks of pregnancy
is a two drug regimen.
And the FDA removed a prior
guideline requiring the person
to meet personally with
a licensed physician.
19 states banned the
administration of an abortion pill
by a telehealth provider,
even if that person is
a licensed physician.
GenBioPro, the manufacturer
of the generic drug
sued the state of Mississippi back in May
after the state passed a law saying that,
"Only a state licensed
physician could prescribe
the medication in person."
The state also requires
women to take the pills
in the presence of a physician.
Now the pharmaceutical
company contends that the FDA
is regulations for dispensing
and prescribing the pill preempt
the state's requirements, and
generally a federal agencies
regulations have supremacy over state law.
However, this is another area
where the Supreme Court is re-evaluating.
This Supreme Court is
currently scaling back
regulatory authority and reinvigorating
the non-delegation doctrine,
all of which could have
significant effects
on what the FDA can and cannot regulate.
And a state is likely to
defend such lawsuits by arguing
that Congress did not give
the FDA explicit authority
to regulate abortion pills and thus,
there's nothing to override state laws.
And then there's interstate travel.
Will women be able to
travel to another state
to get an abortion?
Well, Justice Cavanaugh wrote
in his concurring opinion
that the state cannot
ban women from traveling
from one state to another
to get an abortion.
He called that an easy question to answer.
However, that issue
wasn't before the court
in the Dobb's case,
and his opinion doesn't
have any legal weight.
So is he right?
Well, there's actually not a
lot of case law on the right
to travel between states.
During the Dust Bowl years,
California tried to ban immigration
of people from Oklahoma.
At the time,
California asserted that mass migration
of indigenous people
stressed the state's budget
and created a crisis of health and morals.
The states generally
have broad police power
to regulate health,
safety, welfare and morals
of its citizens,
but the Supreme Court
struck down along the basis
that it was not a valid exercise
of the police power of California,
and that imposes an
unconstitutional burden
upon interstate commerce.
In addition to the Commerce Clause,
people might look to the
Privileges and Immunities Clause
which protects the rights of US citizens
against discriminatory
treatment under the law
of a different state.
And in a 1985 case
called the Supreme Court
of New Hampshire versus Piper,
the US Supreme Court held
that a New Hampshire rule
that limited bar admission
to state residents violated the Privileges
and Immunities Clause.
In 1999, the court decided
another privileges immunities
case Saenz versus Roe.
In that case, the court said,
"That the right to
interstate travel consists
of three components.
One, the right to enter
and leave another state,
two, the right to be
treated as a welcome visitor
when temporarily present
in a another state,
and three the right to be
treated like other citizens
of that state for those travelers
who would like to become
permanent residents.
These cases generally say,
that people have a constitutional right
to move freely between states,
but states are asserting new
powers over their residence.
We've covered the Senate Bill 8,
the Texas Bounty Hunter Law
that allows citizens to sue anyone
who assist someone in
obtaining an abortion.
And since the Supreme Court
didn't strike that law down
other states were inspired
to draft similar laws.
In Missouri lawmakers are debating a law
that would allow the state to
criminally prosecute anyone
who aid someone in getting
an abortion in Missouri,
but also if they help the
person traveled to a state
where the abortion is legal.
And obviously, there are all
sorts of problems underlying
these proposed laws because it purports
to make a criminal
conspiracy out of conduct
that occurs wholly in another state,
where Missouri has no jurisdiction.
And the Missouri legislators
who are drafting the bill
also wants a great civil
liability for anyone in the chain,
who helps the Missouri
resident get an abortion
including people who do the marketing
of an out of state abortion clinic.
Though the Supreme Court has weighed
in on a similar situation before, in 1975,
the Court reversed the
conviction of a Virginia editor
whose newspaper advertised
reproductive health services
offered in New York, the court said,
"A state does not acquire the power
or supervision over the internal affairs
of another state merely
because the welfare
and health of its own
citizens may be affected
when they traveled to that state.
Now, states that are protective
of reproductive rights,
like California and Massachusetts,
are also passing laws
welcoming non-residents
who want abortion services
and shielding their own
citizens from prosecution
and civil liability.
For example, a Massachusetts law exempts
in state health care
providers from liability
for providing services to abortion seekers
from out of state.
The law prohibits the state
from extraditing anyone
to a state that outlaws
abortion and protects people
from having their medical
records disclosed to states
that have criminal penalties for abortion.
But just because the Supreme Court weighed
in on a similar question 45 years ago,
doesn't mean that the
current Supreme Court
is going to have the same outcome,
especially where we're
going to have even more
of a patchwork of different laws,
some of which are trying
to create criminal guilt,
and some of which are
trying to prevent it.
And then of course, there's
the First Amendment.
Since abortion will be a
crime in several states,
some anti-abortion advocates
are already suggesting
that states outlaw any speech
that provides information
that might be used to
terminate a pregnancy,
or encourages an illegal abortion.
And there are a million thorny questions
like this that are going to come up
and it's unknown how the courts
are going to treat these cases.
And then there is the
District of Columbia,
Washington D.C. is not a state.
So now that the cord has sent abortion
back to the states,
what does that mean for D.C. residents?
Well, Washington D.C.
is a federal district
with limited self governance
under the 1973 Home Rule Act.
However, under the Constitution,
Congress is the ultimate
authority over Washington D.C.
So it's likely that the
current Democratic Congress
is not going to do anything
to restrict abortion in D.C.
where it remains legal today.
However, a Republican Congress
might want to end that.
In fact, Representative
Andrew Klein and Republican
from Georgia said his
top focus will now be
"Ending D.C.'s failed experiment
of home rule once and for all."
If Republicans retake
congressional majorities
later this year,
they might decide to
criminalize abortion in D.C.
And that takes us to congressional action.
There are two questions before Congress.
The first is could a Republican Congress
impose a national ban on
abortion if they take power?
Well, in Dobb's, the Supreme Court implied
that there was no due
process right to an abortion
that leaves decisions up to the state,
but we live in a federal system
with the supremacy clause.
So could Congress pass a national law
that banned abortion everywhere
in the United States?
Well, a majority of the court probably
does not think the national abortion ban
would be unconstitutional.
In other words, they could
probably get away with it.
If Congress enacted a national ban,
Congress could cite their power
to regulate interstate commerce
under the Commerce Clause,
which is often how many
different laws are passed,
but that would be pretty easy to do.
Congress could write a law that says
abortions can't be performed.
They use any device
which traveled in interstate commerce,
or using any medication
containing any component
which has traveled in interstate commerce,
or simply the people being
born implicates commerce
because they're going
to engage in commerce,
when they get older or
their parents engage
in commerce has part of the process.
Although many of the courts
conservative justices
have been skeptical of the
government's commerce power.
This situation can be different
if what's being regulated is abortion.
Justice Roberts is the
only conservative justice
on the court who has supported
a federal government's broad right
to regulate interstate commerce.
So his fellow justices
could wind up lobbying him
to uphold a band.
They could also invoke section five
of the 14th Amendment,
the due process clause.
This, of course,
is the same clause that
women once relied on
for the right to abortion,
but Congress could pass a law stating
that fetuses are people
under the 14th amendment
and that they have a right
to life under that section.
The second question is could
a Democratic Congress pass
a nationwide pro-abortion law
making abortion legal in 50 states?
Well, if Congress enacted
a law codifying the right
to an abortion nationwide,
what would happen?
Again, that would depend on
the way that the law is written
and whether the court would
interpret the commerce power
to encompass such a law, but
here I would be more skeptical.
The Supreme Court could
take a narrow interpretation
of commerce power, as
we just talked about.
And it's entirely possible that this court
is so outcome driven
that it would allow commerce
power for a ban on abortion,
but would not allow commerce power
for a nationwide right to abortion.
But you can't know until you try.
Congress could also say that women
have a due process liberty
interest to an abortion,
that would be advisory
to the Supreme Court,
they would be the ultimate arbiters,
but that would put the ball
back with the Supreme Court.
Again, we can guess how the
Supreme Court might find
on that particular theory,
but again, we don't know.
And then there's the question
of all of the other rights
that are implicated by
substantive due process.
Could the Supreme Court start rolling back
a lot of the rights
that we've come to presume
over the last 50 years?
And the answer is very
possibly those rights
have a target on their back:
contraception, interracial marriage,
intimate sexual acts, same sex marriage,
all stem from a common judicial doctrine
notice substantive due process.
Texas Attorney General Ken Paxton says,
he wants to start enforcing
the state's antiquated sodomy laws,
which are unconstitutional under
the current Supreme Court jurisprudence.
But Justice Thomas explicitly says,
that we should do away
with all substantive
due process rights.
Justice Kavanaugh says, the
Dobb should have zero effect
on other rights that originate
in substantive due process,
but the majority and Dobb
suggests that abortion is different
because it implicates potential life.
But also the court engaged
in a deeply rooted analysis
that only looks to history,
and it's hard to see
how any of those other
rights would survive
using the same analysis
that the court engaged in Dobb's.
And the dissenting Dobbs
made this crystal clear,
"And no one should be confident
that this majority is done
with its work.
The right Roe and Casey
recognized does not stand alone.
To the contrary, the court
has linked it for decades
to other settled freedoms
involving bodily integrity,
familial relationships, and procreation.
Most obviously, the right to
terminate a pregnancy arose out
of the right to purchase
and use contraception,
in turn those rights lead more recently
to rights of same sex,
intimacy and marriage.
They are all part of the
same constitutional fabric
protecting autonomous decision making
over the most personal of life decisions.
The majority or to be more accurate,
most of it is eager to tell us today
that nothing it does cast
doubt on the precedents
that do not concern abortion.
But how could that be?
The lone rationale for what
the majority does today
is that the right to elect an abortion
is not deeply rooted in history.
Not until Roe,
the majority argues did
people think abortion fell
within the Constitutions
guarantee of liberty.
The same could be said though of most
of the rights the majority claims
it is not tampering with.
The majority could write just
as long an opinion showing,
for example, that until
the mid 20th century,
there was no support in American law
for a constitutional right
to obtain contraceptives.
So one of two things must be true,
either the majority
does not really believe
in its own reasoning,
or if it does all rights
that have no history stretching back
to the mid 19th century or insecure.
Either the mass of the
majority's opinion is hypocrisy,
or additional constitutional
rights are under threat,
it is one or the other.
So don't be surprised
if this Supreme Court
starts rolling back
these freedoms and rights
and it would probably start
with same sex marriage.
And all of that is why there are a lot
of reproductive health charities out there
that are going to need some help.
And one very small way
that I like to do so is a company
that I work with called Tab For A Cause,
which lets you raise money for charity,
just by opening up tabs
and browsing the internet,
and that includes
reproductive rights charities
because they just launched tab
for reproductive health,
well, because of all of this.
And that lets you raise money
for nonprofit organizations protecting
and providing access to
reproductive health care,
like the Center for Reproductive Rights
and Planned Parenthood.
I know this is just a little thing,
but it's something that
you can do right now
from the comfort of your own home.
The way it works is the Tab For A Cause's
a browser extension that
allows you to pick the charity
of your choice.
And then every time you open up a new tab,
instead of displaying a blank page,
it displays a customizable tab
with a couple of tiny ads.
And the money that you generate
is then given to the charity
that you choose.
You can see in real time how much money
is being generated.
And you can even customize
this tab in the way
that you would like it, and
legal Eagle Tambours have raised
over $35,000 alone.
And I know this because
Tab For A Cause's finances
are 100% transparent,
so you can see for yourself
how much they've raised
and where it's gone.
So if that sounds interesting to you,
if you'd like to make a
small difference together,
all you have to do is click on the link
that's on screen right now,
or in the description to
install the browser extension
and then that's it,
then every page that you
open will create revenue
that goes to charity, in this case,
reproductive health charities.
So all you have to do is click
on the link it's on screen,
or feel free not to as well.
And until next time, I
will see you in court.